there's a difference between a business
making a lot of money and actually being
profitable right absolutely
we want our startup to generate earnings
that eclipse its expenses if our
business generates 1 million a month in
revenue but need to pay in expenses one
and a half we are in a problem however
if in the same scenario our expenses are
only half a million then we are
generating real profits so how do we
make our startup profitable it's very
easy you should follow these three
simple steps first built a wonderful
amazing product so good your user can't
ignore it second charge money for it
third boom profits oh yes that sounds so
easy let's just end the course right
here I mean but just because somebody
puts a price tag on a product doesn't
mean that someone's gonna pay it that's
right as Warren Buffett used to say
price is what you pay value is what you
get this is why you should focus on
creating real value for your customers
people will be willing to pay if they
see and recognize the value in it you
got a bigger chance of building a
profitable business that is making 2
million a year rather than trying to
create the next multi-billion dollar
business if you think on your startup
from this angle you've got a higher
probability to make it happen